the fear for a missing child it's
something far too many have felt here in
Las Vegas and all around the world he
had a good amount of kids who disappear
are found safely but some never return
home Sasha Loftus has more tonight on
the number of children and teens who
vanish here in Las Vegas leaving those
who love them to
eternally Wonder
not knowing is just living at home it's
been 700 days since Lonnie Paulson saw
his daughter smile she's always smiling
since he's heard her laugh two years
since he's known she's safe Lonnie says
Audrey Paulson vanished from Las Vegas
in November of 2020 when she was just 16
years old
the last footage of her getting into a
red car
and his entire entire family has done
everything possible to find her looking
for leads
always worrying it's like you know when
you're waiting for someone to come out
of surgery
like that you know
there's going to be either extremely
good news or extremely bad news like you
know but imagine having that anxiety and
it just you never get that answer
Audrey unfortunately is one of many
according to Nevada child Seekers 8 000
children or teens go missing here in our
state every year with the majority
disappearing right here in Las Vegas
many do return home but some are never
heard from again if you don't find that
child within three hours good chance
you're never going to find that child
retired detective and current co-host of
the problem solver podcast Daniel Miner
says police and other agencies work hard
to bring missing kids home but as time
takes on it becomes more difficult to
move forward if that case gets old
usually goes on the back burner unless a
new lead comes up he tells me that's
where non-profits and private
organizations come in to keep these
cases fresh in people's minds you keep
it out there in the public eye somebody
saw something somebody always seen
something so you want to keep that out
there as of January Nevada ranked ninth
in the nation for human trafficking and
25 percent of those victims start as
children or teens so Miner says it's
important for parents to do what they
can to know what their kids are
associating with in person or online
when you get in these shoes and you find
out those numbers
heartbreaking Lonnie hopes the pain of
sharing his story will help at least one
other person
[Music]
and he still desperately wants to reach
his daughter wherever she is whoever
she's with
to know that she's okay I just want to
know that she said I just want her to
call me and I want to hear from her that
she's safe Sasha Loftus 8 News Now
Lonnie says he has worked with several
non-profit organizations here in Las
Vegas in addition to Metro though he
says Audrey's case changed a few months
ago when she turned to 18. now we do
have a link to resources on our website
you'll find additional information over
there at 8newsnow.com